there are two slightly different
equations for the standard deviation the
difference is that in the first case we
divide by n and in the second case by n
minus 1 but why are there two different
equations usually we want to know the
standard deviation of the population for
example we want to know the standard
deviation of the height of all Austrian
professional soccer players now if we
had the height of really all Austrian
professional soccer players we would
take this equation with 1 divided by n
however it is usually not possible to
serve the entire population so we draw a
sample then we use the sample to
estimate the standard deviation of the
population in that case you use this
equation with n minus one to keep it
simple if our survey doesn't cover the
whole population we always use this
equation